Salut Romain, dis donc, tu fais pipi comment toi ?
Bah, comme ça :
*ziiiip*
Mais non mais, je voulais dire, debout ou assis ?
AAAaaaah !!!
Bon, bah j'termine
Bah ouais
*soupir*
*générique*
J'espère que vous êtes en forme parce qu'aujourd'hui, on va s'attaquer à un gros morceau
C'est à la fois un grand mystère qui a traversé les siècles et
un sortilège maléfique capable de transformer un prince charmant en crapaud
Mais quel est ce prodige ? me demanderez-vous
*Saxophone sensuel*
Hé oui, c'est comme ça
Ça a beau être une source séculaire de différends conjugaux,
de disputes entre amis. Ça a beau les dégoûter eux-mêmes
de s'asseoir sur des toilettes humides et souillées
Rien n'y change, les hommes urinent sur la cuvette.
Ce que je vous propose c'est de voir ensemble pourquoi
Mais aussi si des solutions sont possibles
Pour comprendre le problème il faut bien le disséquer et l'analyser
Point par point
Si les hommes urinent sur la cuvette c'est parce que le jet d'urine peut parfois être difficile
à maîtriser.
D'abord il arrive qu'une forte envie d'uriner provoque un début d'érection.
Une demi-molle comme on dit dans le jargon.
Ce qui rend la visée plus complexe.
Ensuite il y a les variations de pression liées à la poussée.
Un peu comme quand on ferme un robinet et qu'on le rouvre à fond.
Ça gicle, et si le tireur n'anticipe pas, le coup peut partir dans le décor
Autre problème qui peut dérégler la mire les anomalies du jet.
L'urètre peut avoir des petits problèmes
Ca va de la simple inflammation à l'infection en passant par la sténose
c'est à dire le rétrécissement
Et comme c'est par l'urètre que sort l'urine
Si le tuyau est déformé le jet aussi.
On peut avoir des jets en deux parties qui partent dans des directions opposées
Certains appellent ça le strabite
Mais le vrai nom c'est le jet bifide
Dans certains cas on parle aussi de jet en arrosoir ou en spirale
Autant vous dire que c'est pas facile de viser
Bon ça c'est pour
les aléas de la vie
Mais il y a aussi une raison que l'on rencontre au quotidien
Puisqu'elle est directement liée à l'anatomie du pénis
Et du système urinaire masculin en général
Cette particularité lève notamment le voile sur un phénomène sur lequel
les plus grands érudits se sont penchés à travers les siècles
*Musique*
La fameuse dernière goutte, qui apparaît quand on croit que tout est terminé et qui peut
souiller les sous-vêtements, le pantalon ou la cuvette suivant le moment
auquel elle fait son apparition tout en espièglerie.
*sexy saxophone*
Là encore, tout se passe au niveau de l’urètre.
Mais pour bien comprendre, il faut remonter un peu avant la sortie.
*Musique épique*
L'urine part de la vessie, et avant de découvrir la lumière du jour, elle effectue son voyage le long de l'urètre
Lequel, comme la vie, n'est pas un long fleuve tranquille.
En effet, comme vous le constatez, il connait quelques méandres,
comme celui-ci qui nous intéresse particulièrement.
Du fait de sa forme et de son emplacement, l'urine à tendance à y stagner,
comme de l'eau dans une boucle de tuyau d'arrosage.
Elle ne finit par se vider que quand la position du corps
et de la verge fait passer la zone par dessus tout le reste.
Un peu comme quand on lâche le tuyau d'arrosage...il se vide.
Un peu comme quand on sert le thé aussi.
Il y a une solution à ce problème.
C'est un truc d’ostéopathe, et pour réaliser la manœuvre un simple doigt suffit.
Il faut le placer entre l'anus et les testicules, là où l'urètre passe
Vous allez sentir la vibration quand l'urine passe, et si vous appuyez
Ça va couper le jet.
Voilà comment on fait : une fois que vous avez terminé votre petite affaire, appuyez en faisant un mouvement de l'arrière vers l'avant
pour forcer l'urine à se diriger vers la sortie
Comme quand on vide un sachet de mayonnaise
Voilà, le tour est joué il ne vous reste plus qu'à vous laver les mains!
Bon, c'est un peu du bricolage, on ne va pas se mentir,
On ne va pas éluder le cœur du problème.
Si les homme urinent sur la cuvette, c'est avant tout car il urinent debout
Là encore, essayons de comprendre pourquoi les hommes
urinent debout, alors qu'il en mettent partout dans cette position.
La première explication est tout simple:
les hommes urinent debout parce qu'ils peuvent.
Et que c'est bien pratique!
Toutes les femmes qui ont essayé le "Pisse-Debout" vous le dirons.
Et ils urinent debout parce qu'on leur en donne très souvent la possibilité, voire l'obligation.
Le problème c'est que c'est tellement pratique, qu'ils prennent l'habitude,
et du coup même quand ils pourraient uriner assis, bah ils ne le font pas.
Surtout qu'il y a de l'urine sur la lunette, c'est dégueulasse!
Mais j'entends d'autres arguments :
d'abord qu'il existerait une fierté masculine à uriner debout,
qu'on garde de l'enfance et de la première fois où on arrive à faire comme papa.
Alors, disons qu'on est en 2017 et que j'imagine
qu'on doit pouvoir trouver des motifs d'estime de soi
ailleurs que dans la position dans laquelle on vide sa vessie.
Je pense, hein...
Et puis il y a l'argument de la position anatomique.
Une homme, c'est fait pour uriner debout, d'ailleurs tout le monde fait comme ça.
Et bah non, pas tout le monde!
Un tiers des hommes japonais urinent assis
et dans d'autres pays ça se fait accroupi.
Donc, non.
En réalité rien ne permet d'affirmer qu'anatomiquement les hommes ne doivent pas uriner assis.
Leur petit matériel est parfaitement adapté à cette position.
C'est même conseillé à certains patients atteints de troubles du bas-appareil urinaire
parce que les muscles sont plus détendus et que ça permet
une meilleure vidange de la vessie.
Donc la barrière est purement psychologique et culturelle.
Alors attention, ne tombons pas dans l'excès inverse
comme Viggo Hansen qui est un homme politique suédois
qui voulait faire voter une loi pour obliger les hommes à uriner assis
Alors admettons, mais pour convaincre tout le monde
il avait avancé deux arguments :
Uriner assis diminuerait le risque de cancer de la prostate
et ça garantirait une vie sexuelle meilleure et plus longue.
Dans les deux cas ça ne repose sur rien de scientifique.
Donc, les gars, si vous décidez de vous mettre à uriner assis,
faites-le, mais faites-le pour les bonnes raisons.
Comme ne pas en mettre partout, par exemple.
Et pouvoir checker votre smartphone sans risques
et en tout confort...c'est cadeau
Voilà DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour de nouvelles vidéos! En attendant mettez-vous bien,
et surtout...
*Saxophone sensuel*
...portez-vous bien!
*Générique*